hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten welt heute möchte ich euch zeigen
wie man ganz süße halloween aufleger
machen kann und zwar könnt ihr die
aufleger aus blüten passte oder
modelliermasse machen
ich habe leider keine blüten passte da
deswegen mache ich sie aus
modelliermasse und nimmt dazu einfach
etwas von dank und etwas cnc prüfer was
das genau ist habe ich euch schon mal
erklärt und zwar in meinem pinguinen
video und auch in meinem blog da habe
ich den ganzen artikel dazu rund um von
damit über blüten passte und über
modelliermasse ich werde euch jetzt in
diesem video diese einzelnen sachen
nicht mehr erklären was jetzt hier
einfach nur darum gehen soll wie ihre
halloween deko herstellen könnt und ich
werde diese aufleger eben benutzen um
cupcakes damit zu verzieren aber auch um
eine torte damit zu verzieren das werdet
ihr jetzt in diesem video beides
erfahren
jetzt zeigt sich einfach mal wie ich die
aufschläge herstelle und was ihr dazu
benötigt hier habe ich jetzt so ein
kleines stück von dann das sind etwa 100
gramm und da werde ich jetzt etwas cmc 5
mit einem kneten
dann hätte ich meine hände mit etwas
palmen soft und knete des pulver jetzt
ihr schon ein
das gibt dem wandern dann die stabilität
und lässt ihn von dort eben auch
schneller trocknen und start werden
ich habe jetzt hier mal die hälfte weg
genommen die andere hälfte habe ich hier
eingepackt in eine tüte und dann in der
box damit nicht austrocknet jetzt möchte
ich mir den vom land erst mal noch ein
bisschen einfärben und zwar möchte ich
das leicht gelblich und nehmen dazu
meine haarfarbe
ich werde euch bald zeigen welche
passten farben dazu geeignet sind
die wollten passten farben bin hat sich
nämlich nicht mehr weil die einfach
bestimmte zusatzstoffe haben die hier
nicht mehr erlaubt sind
hätte ich meine unterlage leicht mit
pannen und möchte das ganze hilft
ausrollen und dann zu nehme ich meine
silikon starb der hat jetzt bei
abstandhalter das heißt der von dort
wird nur zu dünn ausgerollt wie eben die
höhe der abstandshalter ist und dann
nehme ich mir einfach seinen bisherigen
zum ausstechen
ich möchte eher cupcake aufleger machen
oder eben das zu verwenden einer torte
da kann ich das stück ganz einfach
anheben und zum trocknen weg legen
hier habe ich jetzt einfach noch ein
paar farben mit ausgestopften das waren
jetzt meine zwei großen und ich habe da
noch einen kleinen des hering benutzt
weil ich diese zwei für eine torte
benutzen möchte und die kleineren ebenen
arzt von oskar beck aufleger habe jetzt
hier etwas orange genommen zwei grüne
ein paar weiße und eben noch diese
elfenbeinfarbenen die sind jetzt schon
fast getrocknet und jetzt möchte ich
dafür die deko vorbereiten und zeigt
euch dafür einfach ein paar beispiele
hier etwas schwarze modelliermasse als
auch etwas von damit cmc pulver und aus
den grünen kreisen werden jetzt
frankenstein gesichter deswegen rolle
ich die blüten passte jetzt aus und
möchte damit zuerst einmal die haare
vorne unternehme ich wieder diesen
aussteller den ich auch für die kreise
benutzt habe und steckt es ein mann aus
jetzt kann ich die haare für beide
gesichter gleichzeitig machen und zwar
nehme ich mir
schneider schneider rolle und schneide
hier ein kleines haar musste rein
und dann drehe ich das ganze um und
können hier die runde noch mal beine
benutzen weil es gerne genauer haben
möchte nimmt sich so einen kater
allerdings darf mit dem auf silikon
machen eigentlich nicht schneiden und
dann nehme ich mir einen pinsel und
etwas
kleber das rezept für den klever bekommt
ihr in meinem pinguin video und
bepinselt es hier einmal vollständig
damit unternehmt ihr euch die gesichter
und klebt hier die haare oben am rand
fest danach nehme ich mir etwas meister
modelliermasse und stellt damit die
augen aus und das mache ich einfach mit
so einer noch hülle
und die werden jetzt aufs gesicht
aufgeklebt jetzt könnt ihr euch entweder
aus grün so kleine augenbrauen formen
oder eben aus schwarz ich zeit mich
jetzt noch weiter
so einfach so eine gerade linie die wir
dann auch mithilfe pinselt
jetzt zum vergleich mit den schwarzen
augenbrauen und jetzt bekommt
frankenstein einfach noch zwei augen
zusätzlich hier sechs farben kleber
drauf vor mir aus dem schwarz zwei
küchen und die drücke ich dran da drauf
zum schluss nehme ich mir jetzt noch
einen schwarzen lebensmittel stift und
zeichnet den mundraum
hier habe ich jetzt einen orangefarbenen
cupcake top und habe hier in meiner in
meinem einwegspritze beutel etwas
schwarzes realizing hier möchte ich
jetzt ein spinnennetz aufzeichnen
louis
was auch ziemlich schnell geht ist so
ein kleines geister gesicht und zwar
spritze ich mir damit zwei augen auf
die nasenlöcher
und dann noch den mut auch ganz gut eine
spinne drauf spritzen zum kleinen kopf
den runden körper und dann auf die beine
ich weiß es noch genau um des spieles
sechs oder acht beine hat ich kann es
aber auch nicht google mal wenn ich da
liegen dass ihr kann ich über nacht
wieder einschlafen
aus diesem orangenen möchte ich jetzt
einen kürbis machen es den muss ich noch
zu schneiden und zwar zeichne ich hielt
man mit meinem stift ihr könnt wenn ihr
keine lebensmittel stift habt auch eine
schablone machen zeichne ich jetzt hier
mal so die form des krebses 1
also da unten möchte ich ein bisschen
muss weg werden
dann sage ich nicht hinten ein
und jetzt könnt ihr hier noch ein
gesicht drauf zeichnen entweder mit dem
stift oder mit etwas leise ich mir etwas
grüne modelliermasse und schneit sondern
den stehen noch raus und damit es jetzt
auch dann klebt klebe ich das einmal
drunter und dann falls auch hier nochmal
mit dem stift außen rum
damit ist auch schön zum kürbis pastor
hier möchte ich jetzt noch eine katze
wenn ihr die nicht malen möchtet könnt
ihr euch auch eine schablone machen und
dann aus blüten passte eben ausschneiden
für meine schwarzen hüten pastor
ausgebaut und habe mir hier eine kleine
schablone geschnitten
die kann ich jetzt einfach da drauf
legen
wenn ich so etwas fixieren wollen wir
einfach etwas familien streicht
daraufhin könnte die schablone etwa dann
haben wir mit einem kater richtig schön
um herum schneiden und dann kann ich die
katze draufkleben möchte kann man hier
dann noch zwei augen aufkleben
hier habe ich mir jetzt eine schablone
für eine hexe vorgezeichnet das sind sie
nur grob die umrisse sein und sagen
jetzt mal ausschneiden bei der hexe ist
als genau das gleiche haben jetzt auch
wieder schwarze blüten passte und
schneit einfach der stadt
auch mal passiert dass es hier ab kracht
ein bisschen steigern nicht schlimm das
kann man ja alles wieder 30 leben
dann müsste als vorsichtig sein
so sehen die cupcake top bottom
auswählen sie fertig sind
das ist übrigens eines von sanierungen
von mir die capex torwart ist jetzt
fertig die müssen jetzt allerdings noch
komplett austrocknen und es macht ihr am
besten über nacht falls ihr genug zeit
habt könnt ihr die auch zwei drei tage
trocknen lassen das macht ihn gar nix
ihr könnt die auch schon eine woche
vorher zu bereiten das macht auch nix
jetzt werde ich euch einfach was zeigen
wie ich meine cupcakes damit dekorieren
und später eben auch wie ich meine
tochter mit dekoriere ich habe als
grundlage einfach meinen kürbiskuchen
rezept genommen habe die einfache menge
genommen und die menge hat jetzt
gereicht um eine kuren damit zu backen
mit 20 zentimetern durchmesser und auch
um aus dem gleichen tag noch zwölf
martins herzustellen
das heißt wenn ihnen nur zwölf mal fit
machen wollt oder nur einen kleinen
kuchen daneben da einfach die hälfte des
kassetten ich sage ich jetzt erst mal
wie ich die capex gemacht habt was ich
für frosting benutze und zeigt euch dann
wie ich die cupcakes wie dekoriere zu
sehen meine muffins aus ich hab dir
einfach in so einer silikon form
gebacken
das geht ganz gut dass sie jetzt hier
nur 24 68 die andere hat die sanierung
schon aufgegessen
das hätten habe ich das nicht mehr so
viele unternehmen jetzt einfach aus der
form heraus und lasse einmal komplett
ausfüllen
wir fordern das frosting drauf kommt und
dann eben schlussendlich die deko für
die capex benutze ich ein white cream
cheese frosting das kennt ihr aus meinem
allerersten cupcakes video und zwar
verwende ich dafür 150 gramm frischkäse
150 gramm capone und 150 gramm
puderzucker
das ganze kommt jetzt einfach in meine
rührschüssel rein und wird da dann auf
höchster stufe kurz verrührt bis sich
der puderzucker mit den restlichen
zutaten verbunden habe ihr dürft es aber
nicht zu lange ruhen damit das frosting
nicht flüssig wert
auch schon als ich bin jetzt einfach von
der niedrigsten stufe bis zur höchsten
gegangen und dann auch gleich wieder
ausgemacht
das ging jetzt etwa so 10 15 sekunden
das frosting habe ich jetzt eben einen
spritzbeutel gefühl bittner schöne und
spritzte sitzt einfach je nach belieben
auf die kappe und ich habe jetzt noch
ziemlich viel frosting übrig das kommt
auch daher dass hier schon vier muffins
fehlen aber es reicht auch wenn ihr mit
100 gramm mascarpone frischkäse und
puderzucker arbeitet und jetzt könnt ihr
eure dekorationen da drauf setzen
falls ihr das ohne deco machen rollt die
cupcakes können doch die so lassen mit
der das sind bestreuen
oder ein paar wahl müssen dekorieren
aber ich setze da ist mein halloween
deko drauf und zu sehen dann die
fertigen grusel halloween muffins aus
die würde ich jetzt bis zum verzehren
auch in den kühlschrank stellen
und so sind sie fertig die kag wolltet
ihr am besten direkt servieren
damit die modelliermasse also diese
blüten passte
durch dieses greenpeace france ging
einfach nichts zerschmilzt deswegen am
besten einfach kurz vorm servieren die
capex top drauf legen das ist ja auch
schnell gemacht und dann sind sie eben
wie gesagt so wir breit
jetzt zeige ich euch wie ich meine
tochter mit von und einkleiden und zeigt
euch dann wie ich sie dekorieren
die von dort habe ich jetzt ganz schnell
mit fondant eingekleidet ich habe euch
das ist ein schnelldurchlauf gezeigt
weil ich ja schon ein paar videos
darüber gemacht habe ich werde euch aber
noch einmal alles schritt für schritt
ganz genau erklären also wirklich ganz
klein schnittigen ganz einfachen
schritten damit auch jeder jeden schritt
nachvollziehen kann
das wird ab jetzt den rahmen dieses
videos sprengen deswegen habe ich jetzt
kurz gehalten weil es heute einfach um
die halloween deko gehen soll
und jetzt war die tote eine nach dem
kühlschrank das müsst ihr nicht machen
könnt ihr aber machen dann ist die
oberfläche nämlich schönen angetrocknet
und jetzt werde ich einfach noch die
deko um die torte herum machen und wie
ich das mache zeige ich euch jetzt also
wenn ich die torte praxis bei mir immer
so aus ich habe immer so eine zeichnung
ungefähr wie eben meine torte später
aussehen soll
das gibt mir eine ganz gute hilfe weil
ich dann einfach weiß was ich machen
muss hier habe ich jetzt meine fertige
torte die ist wie gesagt vollständig
getrocknet und jetzt werde ich hier auf
dieser seite hier meine dekor zu
bereiten
und jetzt habe ich mir hier wieder
schablonen gemacht und die höhe passt
natürlich direkt zur torte also die deko
passt da gut an den rand werde ich das
wie auch mit der hexe und mit der katze
vorhin einfach nach schablone
ausschneiden
und jetzt überlege ich mir was ich wo
ankleben möchte und wie pinsel dass
einfach alles mit etwas kleber
jetzt spricht sich noch die feinheiten
mit etwas realizing auf
und jetzt wird sich da oben so ein
bisschen was ein damit eben die hexe mit
dem montag drauf passt ich möchte jetzt
nicht ganz wichtig sondern leicht
versetzt kleine stelle ein
dann kommt da etwas cleverer und dann
setze ich hier die hexe drauf nicht so
die ganze team muss fixiere ich das
einmal mit zwei schaschlikspieß oder
einen das reicht schon schlägt es hier
rein dann kann das ein bisschen an
trocknen und da werde ich dann später
das loch einfach verdecken und jetzt
schreibe ich hier oben drauf einfach nur
einen schriftzug happy halloween das
könnte aber auch natürlich weglassen
so sieht die torte jetzt aus und ich
hatte hier noch ein paar fledermäuse
ausgeschnitten einfach auch mit
schablone oder wenn ihr könnt eine gute
hand und hab da einen draht reingesteckt
dass sich einfach im rat den ich mal so
gekauft hatte und die möchte ich jetzt
in die torte 1 scheibe aber damit die
der draht nicht in berührung mit der
torte kommt stecke ich da durch einen
strohhalm hinein den ich zurecht
geschnitten habe ich würde das ganze
jetzt hier reinstecken
dann fühle ich öffnen etwas eissing
hinein und steckt dann meine fledermäuse
rein
das heißt so meine kleine halloween
anregungen für euch für übermorgen
ich hoffe der ein oder andere wird das
rezept mal nachmachen uns die ideen
umsetzen
ihr könnt ja diese kampik aufleger mit
jedem motiv bemalen oder damit
dekorieren eben je nachdem was ihr gerne
mit was ihr gemacht ob ihr gerne mit
rolle von land arbeitet oder lieber mit
icing
ich wünsche euch jetzt noch eine ganz
schöne woche wünsche euch eine schöne
halloween-party falls ihr eine feiert
und dann sehen wir uns schon ganz bald
wieder mit einem neuen rezept und die
ganz genauen mengenangaben zum rezept
also auch als krebs kurven rezept
verlinkt ich euch nochmal unten
ich verliere ich auch noch mal dass
nutella
video weil das highlighting mit drin ist
außerdem fällig ich euch auch noch das
pinguin video weil ihr den gebern und
mal sehen könnt wie man den herstellt
und alles andere findet ihr auf meinem
blog auf www.starbett.de da würde ich
mich freuen wenn ihr da mal vorbeischaut
wenn ich das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine wertung freuen teilt
das video mit euren freunden falls es
euch gefällt und dann sehen wir schon
ganz bald